SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. IF MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE COULD COME TO
ROOM 113 SO WE COULD ESTABLISH
QUORUM, THAT WOULD BE GREAT. WE
HAVE ONE BILL AND ONE RESOLUTION
ON TODAY'S HEARING AGENDA. THE
BILL WILL BE HEARD PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE 29.1 D AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S AMENDMENTS
CREATED A NEW BILL AND UPON
RETURN TO THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE, THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE REFERRED THE BILL TO
THIS COMMITTEE FOR HEARING. WE
WILL HEAR BECAUSE THE AUTHOR IS
NOT HERE. WE WILL HEAR THE
RESOLUTION FIRST, AND SO WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AT THIS
POINT, SO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT, YOU ARE HERE TO PRESENT
YOUR RESOLUTION, YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, CHAIRMAN
MIN. AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. ACR 120 DECLARES A
LEGISLATOR'S SUPPORT FOR NEW AND
EXISTING MARINE PROTECTED AREAS
AND URGES STATE AGENCIES,
COUNCILS AND COMMISSIONS TO
PRIORITIZE THESE AREAS. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE MARINE
LIFE PROTECTION ACT IN 1999,
WHICH SET UP A PROCESS TO
ESTABLISH MPAS USING SCIENTIFIC
DATA. THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE MANAGES THE
PROGRAM AND EVERY TEN YEARS
SOLICITS INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS
TO UPDATE THE ACT. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HAS 124 PROTECTED
AREAS, WHICH COVERS
APPROXIMATELY 852MI² OF STATE
WATERS, AND THAT EQUATES TO
ABOUT 16% OF ALL THE COASTAL
WATERS COVERED BY THE BY AN MPA.
AS THE CLIMATE CONTINUES TO
CHANGE, WE MUST DO ALL WE CAN TO
PROTECT SENSITIVE AREAS AND
ECOSYSTEMS, BOTH ON LAND AND IN
WATER. MARINE PROTECTED AREAS
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BOLSTER OCEAN
ECOSYSTEM HEALTH, IMPROVE
RESILIENCE OF FISHERIES AND
STORE CARBON. ALL OF WHICH HELPS
TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE. WITH
ME TODAY, I HAVE LAURA DUNHAM
FROM THE ENVIRONMENT, OUR
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
THOMAS VALADEZ FROM AZUL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR PURPOSES OF
TIME, WE'LL LIMIT EACH WITNESS'S
TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES. OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIR. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT, FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. AND SO MY
NAME IS LAURA DIÆN. I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE REALLY
PROUD TO JOIN FELLOW
CO-SPONSORS, NRDC, AZUL, AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER IN
BRINGING FORWARD THIS
RESOLUTION. CALIFORNIA IS AN
INCREDIBLE BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOT
WITH WHALES, SEA OTTERS, SEA
TURTLES, OTHER WILDLIFE THAT
CALL IT HOME. AND MORE THAN 20
YEARS AGO, THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TOOK AN INCREDIBLE
STEP TO PROTECT THAT
BIODIVERSITY BY PASSING THAT
LAW, THE MARINE LIFE PROTECTION
ACT AND WE'VE NOW HAD THIS
MARINE PROTECTED AREA NETWORK IN
PLACE FOR MORE THAN A DECADE.
AND THE FIRST BIG REPORT CARD
CAME OUT AND IT SHOWED IT'S
REALLY WORKING. AND THERE'S MORE
BIODIVERSITY, THERE'S MORE FISH
WITHIN OUR MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS, AND THEY'RE REALLY
ALLOWING WILDLIFE TO THRIVE
WHERE WE HAVE THESE STATE PARKS
IN THE WATER, AND THE, THE OTHER
GOOD NEWS IS THE SCIENCE IS
SHOWING THAT THE MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS ARE MORE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THE STRESSORS THAT
WE'RE SEEING, HOWEVER, OUR OCEAN
IS STILL THREATENED TODAY. WE'RE
SEEING MORE POLLUTION PROBLEMS.
WE'RE SEEING MAJOR IMPACTS FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE AND AN INCREASE
IN MARINE HEAT WAVE EVENTS,
WHICH ARE HAVING CASCADING
IMPACTS ON THE ECOSYSTEM FOR
EXAMPLE, MORE THAN 90% OF OUR
STATE'S KELP FOREST WAS
DECIMATED IN JUST THE LAST
DECADE. AND AS THE STATE IS
TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO PROTECT
30% OF OUR OCEAN BY 2030.
LEADING THE CHARGE FOR MORE
NATURE. WE REALLY NEED TO BUILD
ON THE PROVEN TRACK RECORD AND
THE SUCCESS OF OUR STATE'S
MARINE PROTECTED AREA NETWORK AS
WE MOVE FORWARD, AND I THINK THE
PUBLIC AGREES MORE THAN THERE
WAS. A RECENT PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA POLL
THIS PAST JULY, AND THEY FOUND
81% OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
EXPANDING CALIFORNIA'S MARINE
PROTECTED AREA NETWORK. SO WE
URGE AND I THANK YOU. TOMAS IS
GOING TO COME UP. THIS TWO
MINUTES AND YOU CAN BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. TOMAS VALDES THANK YOU.
THOMAS GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF. MY
NAME IS THOMAS VALADEZ. I'M THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY ASSOCIATE. FOR
US, WOOD AZUL IS AN OCEAN
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION WORKING
WITH THE LATINX COMMUNITY TO
PROTECT THE OCEAN AND COAST.
CALIFORNIA IS A GLOBAL
CONSERVATION LEADER. AS THE
FIRST US STATE TO COMMIT TO THE
30 BY 30 GOAL. HOW WE GET THERE
MATTERS. OUR AGENCIES HAVE
LIMITED TIME AND RESOURCES, WITH
ONLY A LITTLE OVER FIVE YEARS
LEFT BEFORE 2030, CALIFORNIA
MUST PRIORITIZE ACTIONS SUCH AS
EXPANDING OUR MPA NETWORK TO
MAXIMIZE BIODIVERSITY AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE BENEFITS,
EXPANDING OUR MPA NETWORK IS ONE
OF THE BEST OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE TO PROTECT OUR STATE'S
COAST AND OCEAN AND INCREASE
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS. AZUL HAS LONG ADVOCATED
THAT THE PURSUIT OF THE 30 BY 30
GOAL MUST ADDRESS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN PLACED
ON LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO THE
OCEAN AND ITS BENEFITS. THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT AND
CHAIRMAN FOR BRINGING ATTENTION
TO THIS ADMINISTRATION. PRIORITY
WE RESPECTFULLY WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY SHOULD LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT, WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, DO
WE JUST HAVE ONE? ALL RIGHT. YOU
HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE IT. IF I TAKE
FOUR MINUTES, PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO THROW ME OUT. MARK SMITH, ON
BEHALF OF A COALITION OF
RECREATIONAL ANGLING
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING THE
COASTAL CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA, THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION, ALL
WATERS BACKCOUNTRY HUNTERS AND
ANGLERS RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
RESOLUTION AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THE AUTHOR IS AN ESTEEMED
GENTLEMAN WHO WE'VE WORKED WITH
PRODUCTIVELY ON A NUMBER OF
ISSUES, BUT DO HAVE A COUPLE
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THIS
RESOLUTION. THE MPA DEBATE IS A
RATHER ACRIMONIOUS ONE. SOME OF
THE MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE
UNDOUBTEDLY ARE AWARE OF THAT.
WE'RE AROUND WHEN THE MPA
NETWORK WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED,
OVER A DECADE AGO, THE PUBLIC
PROCESS FOR THAT SHOULD BE AT
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION IN
THE COMMITTEES AND IN THE SPACES
WHERE PUBLIC DIALOG IS BROUGHT
FORWARD IN A MEANINGFUL MANNER.
WE OBJECT TO THIS RESOLUTION
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
SPONSORS OF THE RESOLUTION, WHO
ARE ALSO THE PETITIONERS IN THE
CURRENT MPA DECADAL REVIEW
PROCESS, ARE SEEKING A MASSIVE
EXPANSION OF THE MPA NETWORK AND
USING A RESOLUTION LIKE THIS TO
INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME OF WHAT
SHOULD BE A DISCUSSION IN A
PUBLIC BODY IN A PUBLIC FORUM.
BEYOND THAT, WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE OTHER ALTERNATIVES TO
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S
BIODIVERSITY AND ACHIEVING OUR
30 BY 30 GOALS BEYOND A MASSIVE
EXPANSION OF THE MPA NETWORK,
THERE ARE THOSE WHO SUGGEST THAT
IN ORDER TO MEET 30 BY 30
PROTECTION STANDARDS, WE NEED TO
DOUBLE THE EXISTING MPA NETWORK.
ALL OF THE STRESSORS THAT WERE
MENTIONED BY THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE IMPACTS OF RECREATIONAL
ANGLING. THEY HAVE TO DO WITH
MUCH LARGER GLOBAL IMPACTS THAT
ARE AFFECTING OUR OCEANS AND OUR
FISHERIES. THE LAST THING I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT IS THAT THERE
IS A LITTLE BIT OF AN IRONY
HERE. ONE OF THE TENETS OF 30 BY
30 IS ACCESS FOR ALL,
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL,
PARTICULARLY TO COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND FOLKS WHO DON'T OFTEN
RECREATE OUT IN THE OCEAN SPACE
THE MPA NETWORKS AND PREVIOUS
VERSIONS OF THIS RESOLUTION
CALLED FOR WHAT ARE KNOWN AS
HIGHLY PROTECTED MPAS, WHICH
PROHIBIT ALL ACCESS, INCLUDING
RECREATIONAL ACCESS. WE ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THAT RUNS CONTRARY TO
THE PRINCIPLES OF 30 BY 30, AND
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THE
RESOLUTION TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE
SEEING NONE, WE WILL ALLOW THE
AUTHOR TO, I GUESS WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DÍAS. DO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? SENATOR LAIRD? YES,
I HAVE A COMMENT AND THEN A
QUESTION, AND HE'LL NEED TO HEAR
THIS TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE. SO I'M
GLAD YOU DIDN'T GO TO HIS CLOSE,
THE COMMENT IS, IS THAT THERE'S
SORT OF A CLASH IN SOME WAYS OF
GOALS HERE IN AS WAS INTIMATED,
I WAS REALLY INVOLVED IN, IN THE
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS AND, AND
NEGOTIATING WITH THE TRIBES TO
BRING THEM ON BOARD AND DOING
LOTS OF THINGS. AND THE THING
IS, IS THE MARINE PROTECTED AREA
SYSTEM IS REALLY BASED ON
SCIENCE AND THAT AND THEN
ADAPTIVELY MANAGED AGAINST THE
SCIENCE AND THE CONFLICT HERE
IS, IS THE GOVERNOR SET A
NUMERICAL GOAL AND THE NUMERICAL
GOAL ISN'T NECESSARILY BASED ON
THE SCIENCE. AND SO AND WE WERE
TALKING BRIEFLY BECAUSE I GAVE
YOU A HEADS UP AND LARA WALKED
UP AND LARA AND AZUL PROPOSED AN
ADDITIONAL MARINE PROTECTED AREA
OFF OF SANTA CRUZ THAT LED TO,
LET'S JUST SAY, A LIVELY
DISCUSSION AND I FACILITATED A
15 STAKEHOLDER MEETING FOR THE
CONVERSATION THAT MAYBE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN HELD BEFORE IT WAS
PROPOSED. AND I THINK IN, IN
LAURA'S DEFENSE, SHE REALLY
THOUGHT FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
IS THE SCIENCE PROCESS AND WE
WILL LAUNCH IT INTO THAT
PROCESS. BUT THERE WERE VARIOUS
PEOPLE THAT WEREN'T DIDN'T HAVE
BASES TOUCHED THAT CAME OUT
AGAINST IT, VERY CONCERNED AT
THE BEGINNING. AND
INTERESTINGLY, GIVEN MARK'S
TESTIMONY, IT WAS LOCAL SURFERS
AND SPEAR FISHERMEN THAT WHOSE
ACTIVITIES REALLY DON'T AFFECT
THE OUTCOME OF THE TAKE AND
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS THAT WERE
MOST IN OPPOSITION. AND, AND I
THINK IN THE MEETING IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THERE WAS A WAY TO DO
THE MPA AND ALLOW CERTAIN TYPES
OF RECREATIONAL FISHING THAT
WOULD HAVE ADDRESSED THE ISSUE.
AND WITH MARK'S TESTIMONY, I
WOULD SAY TO HIM THAT THAT WOULD
BE ADDRESSED IN THE PROCESS IN A
WAY THAT I THINK THEIR ADVOCATES
THAT ARE VERY ENVIRONMENTAL,
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
RECREATIONAL FISHING. BUT THE
PROBLEM IS, IS THE GOVERNOR HAS
SAID WE HAVE TO HAVE 30% OF OUR
WATERS AND THE CHAIR FACILITATED
A HEARING IN FRONT OF THIS VERY
COMMITTEE ON HOW WE WERE GOING
TO GET THERE. AND ONE OF THE
HARDEST THINGS WAS, IS
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE PERCENT
THAT'S BEEN PROTECTED ALREADY.
AND WHAT YOU COULD GET FROM
DOING THE MARINE PROTECTED AREAS
AT THE IN GENERAL, AT THE
CHUMASH SANCTUARY. AND THEN
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE US? AND IT
LEAVES US SETTING A NUMERICAL
GOAL WHERE IT ISN'T NECESSARILY
BASED ON THE SCIENCE. THAT IS
WHERE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PROGRAM IS. AND SO I THINK I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO FORCE THE
CONVERSATION. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS RESOLUTION DOES. BUT IT IS
A CONVERSATION AND IT REALLY AND
FOR THE RECORD, THE THING THAT
DROVE ME CRAZY WHEN I HAD A
POSITION THAT IT DRIVES SENATOR
GROVE CRAZY THAT I MENTIONED, IS
THAT IT TOOK AGES FOR THE
SCIENCE TO COME. AND SO THE
FIRST PROTECTED AREA WASN'T EVEN
STATE. IT WAS OFF OF THE CHANNEL
ISLANDS. IT MAY WELL BE IN YOUR
DISTRICT. AND THERE'S THIS
INTERESTING THING THAT ALL OF A
SUDDEN PEOPLE WERE FISHING A
HALF A MILE OR A QUARTER MILE
OUTSIDE THE BOUNDARY, AND THEY
WERE GETTING BIG LOBSTERS. AND
SO IT WAS A STATEMENT THAT IT
WAS WORKING. BUT THE SCIENCE
HADN'T CAUGHT UP WITH THE
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE THAT IT WAS
HAPPENING. AND YET IT IS THE
SCIENCE THAT ALLOWS US TO
ADAPTIVELY MANAGE AND TO GO TO
PEOPLE IN THE FISHING INDUSTRY
AND OTHER PLACES AND SAY, THIS
IS WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
AND I REALLY WORKED HARD ORPHALI
WITH THE GUY THAT PASSED AWAY
WHO WAS HEAD OF THE FISHING
THING. PARDON YEAH. ZEKE GRADER.
HE AND I WORKED AGAINST OFFSHORE
OIL CLOSELY IN THE 80S AND HE
WAS LIKE BUT WE NEED OTHER
THINGS TOO. AND I SAID, THIS
ISN'T MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE TO THE
OTHER THINGS. THIS IS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE AND WORKED
REALLY HARD WITH HIM TO GET HIM
TO DO IT. SO THAT'S A LONG
WINDED QUESTION OF WOULD YOU
COMMENT ON THE RELATIONSHIP OF
TRYING TO BE CLEAR WITH THE
SCIENCE AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THE NUMERICAL GOAL IN
YOUR RESOLUTION? AND BEFORE WE
HAVE YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION,
SINCE WE HAVE QUORUM HERE, LET'S
ESTABLISH THAT ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YOU HAVE A FEW MOMENTS TO THINK
ABOUT YOUR ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU. YES. ALL
RIGHT. I'M DOING THE ROLL. ROLL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
MIN HERE. MIN HERE. CIERTO ALAN
DALLY. HERE HERE, HERE. DALLY
HERE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN, HERE.
GROVE. GROVE. HERE. HURTADO
LAIRD. HERE. LAIRD. HERE LEMON.
HERE. HERE LEMON. HERE. PADILLA
STERN. STERN. HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU, ASSISTANT
NOTES THE QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO SENATOR
LAIRD'S QUESTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE QUESTION.
AND THE DEEP BACKGROUND YOU HAVE
IN IN THIS AREA WITH ALL OF YOUR
EXPERIENCES AND RELATING THE
PARTICULAR CONCERN. FIRST, I
THINK YOU ALL RECOGNIZE YOU HAVE
GREAT STAFF, AND I'D LIKE TO
JUST POINT OUT THE FIRST
SENTENCE OF YOUR STAFF, SUMMARY
OF THE OF THE BILL OF THE
LANGUAGE, AND THAT IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION CALLS UPON SPECIFIED
STATE AGENCIES TO PRIORITIZE, AS
SUPPORTED BY SCIENCE AND PUBLIC
PROCESS, AND THE ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT PROCESS. THE
EXPANSION OF MARINE PROTECTED
AREA NETWORKS FOLLOWING. AND IT
CONTINUES. SO THE VERY FIRST
SENTENCE OF THE OF YOUR STAFF'S
SUMMARY OF THE RESOLUTION
EMPHASIZES BOTH THE COMMITMENT
TO A SCIENTIFIC PROCESS AND A
PUBLIC PROCESS, AND THE ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT PROCESS THAT IS OUT
THERE. NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO, YES, THERE IS A 30 BY 30
GOAL OUT THERE. BUT WHETHER
THERE WAS A 30 BY 30 GOAL OR NOT,
WHERE WE ARE WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
AND ITS IMPACTS WOULD CAUSE ME
TO BE SUPPORTIVE AND COME
FORWARD WITH THIS RESOLUTION,
BECAUSE A RESOLUTION, I THINK IS
SIMPLY ONE WAY FOR US AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO SEND THE MESSAGE
THAT WE ARE INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WHAT IS GOING
ON. WE ARE, WE ARE RECOGNIZING
THAT MARINE PROTECTED AREAS IS
JUST ONE OF MANY TOOLS THAT ARE
OUT THERE. AND WE'RE
HIGHLIGHTING THAT THERE IS GREAT
VALUE IN MOVING FORWARD. I HAVE,
AS MENTIONED BY THE OPPOSITION
SPEAKER, I FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH, WITH THE
FISHING INDUSTRY. WE'VE PULLED A
BILL TO SPEND MORE TIME WORKING
WITH THEM. I THINK THEY'VE BEEN
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT, THIS DOES
BY NO MEANS SAYS PRIORITIZE 30
BY 30 OVER SCIENCE OVER PROCESS,
OVER ANYTHING ELSE. THIS SIMPLY
IS ACKNOWLEDGING THE TREMENDOUS
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE. THE FINAL
THING I WOULD OFFER TO YOU,
SENATOR, AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IS I. I WENT TO
SCHOOL ON THE EAST COAST, AND I
SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME
MONITORING AS AN ECONOMICS
MAJOR. THE WHOLE ISSUE OF TRYING
TO DEAL WITH THE FISHING STOCKS
AND THE STEADY COLLAPSE OF
FISHING STOCKS ON THE EAST COAST,
AND THERE IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
A DEBATE OVER THE SCIENCE, AND
WE WANT OUR BEST REGULATORY
AGENCIES USING THE BEST POSSIBLE
SCIENCE. BUT CONSISTENTLY OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, WHEN THE WHEN
THE SCIENTISTS CAME IN AND SAID,
YOU NEED TO CUT YOUR TAKE BY 30%
AND THAT WILL STABILIZE THE
FISHERIES. THE FISHERMEN FOUGHT
LIKE CRAZY AND THEY ONLY WERE
WILLING AND THEY WEREN'T WILLING
TO ACCEPT ANY CUT. AND THEN WHEN
THE SCIENCE CAME BACK THREE
YEARS LATER AND SAID, NOW YOU
HAVE TO CUT BY 60% TO SAVE THIS
FISHERY, THE FISHERMEN WOULD
ONLY AGREE TO A 30% CUT AND THEY
CHASED IT LITERALLY ALL THE WAY
DOWN OVER AND OVER AGAIN. NOW
THIS IS THIS IS DIFFERENT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RECREATION.
BUT MY POINT IS THAT THERE IS
THERE HAS BEEN RESISTANCE AND
IT'S VALUABLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY THAT THE
CLIMATE CRISIS JUSTIFIES US
SIMPLY MAKING A STATEMENT THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THE VALUABLE
TOOLS THAT ARE OUT THERE. SO
AGAIN, I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SENATOR GROVE,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I DO AGREE
HALFWAY WITH MY COLLEAGUE THAT
USED TO BE THE FORMER CHAIR OF
NATURAL RESOURCES, FORMER
SECRETARY. I APOLOGIZE,
SECRETARY. I KNOW EXACTLY,
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES.
SO I DO, BUT I HAVE A COMMENT
THEN I HAVE A QUESTION AS HE DID
THE INTENT OF THE MPAS IS TO
ENSURE HEALTHY HABITATS BY
PROVIDING A VARIETY OF SPECIES,
WHICH REPRESENTS SIGNIFICANT
FOOD RESOURCES AND MAJOR
SEGMENTS OF THE POPULATION.
EXPANDING EXISTING AREAS WILL
NOT DO THAT MUCH TO PROTECT THIS
OTHER SPECIES, AND IT CREATES A
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC IMPACT ON
THOSE INDIVIDUALS, LIKE MARK
SAID, THAT ARE EITHER COMMERCIAL
OR SPORTS FISHERMEN. AND THE
REASON WHY I SAY THAT IS BECAUSE
AND YOU LOOK AT I GUESS I'LL USE
FARMING AS AN EXAMPLE BECAUSE I
DON'T OPERATE, I DON'T HAVE A
COASTAL AREA. RIGHT? SO I DON'T
DEAL WITH FISHERMEN A LOT. I EAT
FISH, I LIKE FISH, I LIKE IT TO
BE CAUGHT AND BROUGHT TO THE
STORES, COMMERCIAL FISHING, THAT
KIND OF STUFF. BUT, IT DRIVES ME
NUTS. AND I'M. AND I'M SURE AND
I'M GOING TO SPEAK FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON, AND
SHE'S PROBABLY GOING TO OBJECT
AND DO A POINT OF ORDER AS WELL,
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD FOR US
TO SIT IN COMMITTEES AND LISTEN
TO PEOPLE TALK TO US ABOUT HOW
FARMERS NEED TO, ADJUST TO
REDUCED WATER USAGE AND HOW WE
NEED TO REGULATE WATER FOR
SUSTAINABLE. WE BOTH HAVE
FARMERS IN OUR DISTRICT THAT ARE
FIVE, SIX, SEVEN GENERATION
FARMERS. THEY KNOW HOW TO BE
SUSTAINABLE. THEY KNOW HOW TO
GROW A SUSTAINABLE CROP. BUT
WHEN YOU COME IN AND SAY, THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE THESE STEPS
WITH THIS RESOLUTION AND
FISHERMEN ALREADY KNOW, THEY'RE
PROBABLY THE FIRST ONES IN THE
PROCESS TO TAKE STEPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE FOOD SUPPLY, BECAUSE
IT'S THEIR JOB, GENERATIONS OF A
JOB. THERE'S PROBABLY 200
FISHING VESSELS IN JUST SAN
DIEGO ALONE THAT WILL BE LIKELY
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY POLICIES
THAT WILL BE CREATED BY THIS
RESOLUTION. EACH OF THOSE
VESSELS ARE FAMILY OWNED. YOU
MIGHT HAVE 4 OR 5 ON THE SHIP
AND MAYBE 6 OR 8 ON THE SHORE.
SO VERY SMALL FAMILY BUSINESSES
AND THEY ALSO SUPPORT, LIKE I
SAID, INLAND JOBS AS WELL. IF
YOU GO TO THE MARKET AND SELL
THE PRODUCT AND, AND THE PEOPLE
THAT TRANSPORT IT AND ALL THAT,
THEY ALREADY HAVE CHALLENGING
SITUATIONS GOING ON TO BE ABLE
TO BE SUSTAINABLE WITH NHIÀU,
NOT HAVING NEW TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE. YOU LOOK AT SPORTS
FISHERMEN, THEY MIGHT HAVE A 10
OR 12 PERSON CREW THAT TAKE A
GROUP OF PEOPLE OUT TO DO SPORTS
FISHING. ALL THESE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE IMPACTED BY
LEGISLATION THAT THIS RESOLUTION
WOULD PROVIDE. I'M SURE, IT
LEADS TO LOSS OF BUSINESS
ACTIVITY, LOSS OF JOBS, LOSS OF
REVENUES. AND LIKE I SAID, I
TALKED TO A MARITIME LADY IN SAN
DIEGO WHO'S LIKE, THEY CALL HER
CAPTAIN ANNE. AND SHE IS I DON'T
KNOW, SIXTH GENERATION MARITIME
PROFESSIONALS. SHE'S ON A
MARITIME BOARD, AND SHE SEES THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS THAT POLICIES
COMING OUT OF THIS BUILDING ARE
GOING TO AFFECT THEIR ENTIRE WAY
OF LIFE THAT THEY'VE HAD FOR
GENERATIONS. SO I GUESS, DO YOU
HAVE ANY DATA OR HAVE YOU LOOKED
AT THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS?
YOU'VE LOOKED AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE CLEARLY, BUT
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE IMPACT ON
THE ECONOMIC SITUATION THAT A
RESOLUTION AND POLICIES COMING
FORWARD BECAUSE OF THIS
RESOLUTION WOULD HAVE ON, THE
BUSINESS CLIMATE AND THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND THE
ACCESS THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE TO LEGACY SMALL BUSINESSES
FOR DECADES. SURE. I'D BE HAPPY
TO RESPOND. I FEEL PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT I HAD A LONG LINE
DRIFTNET, BAN, A BILL THAT WOULD
WOULD DO THAT, BUT PHASE IT OUT
VERY SLOWLY OVER A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME SO THAT A CURRENT
OPERATOR WOULD BE ABLE TO STAY
IN BUSINESS AS LONG AS THAT
CURRENT OPERATOR LIVED. IT'S
THAT THAT THE CURRENT OPERATOR
COULDN'T KEEP TRANSFERRING THE
PERMIT FOR LONG LINE, WHICH
SCIENCE IS SHOWING US. LOTS OF
EVIDENCE OF NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
BUT IT WAS THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. WE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE. WE'VE NOT WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS RESOURCE
DEPLETION IF THERE AREN'T GOING
TO BE SOME ECONOMIC IMPACTS.
IT'S JUST THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE
CAN DO THAT. WE HAVE TO CHANGE
SOME THINGS AND THAT CHANGE
REQUIRES SOME ECONOMIC
DISLOCATION. THE KEY IS TO MAKE
THE DISLOCATIONS BE AS MODERATE
AND AS PLANNED AND AS
APPROPRIATE AS POSSIBLE. AND I
THINK THAT A BILL THAT, THAT
IDENTIFIED HOW LONG THAT YOU
COULD CONTINUE YOUR BUSINESS, AS
LONG AS YOU ARE OPERATING. SO
YOU'RE ASKING ME, DO I HAVE ANY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH DATA
AND LOOKING AT THE BUSINESS SIDE
OF IT? I AND I JUST WANT TO JUST
MENTION FOR PURPOSES OF TIME, WE
HAVE 20 MINUTES LEFT. WE HAVE
ANOTHER BILL. THIS IS A
RESOLUTION. THIS IS NOT A SO
YES. SO MY POINT IS AND IF YOU
COULD LET HIM ANSWER THE
QUESTION THEN WE'LL RETURN BACK
TO YOU. AND MY POINT IS AND I
PULLED THAT AND I ACTUALLY
PULLED THAT BILL BECAUSE OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. SO YES, AS
A LEGISLATOR I'VE PAID ATTENTION
TO THE ECONOMIC SIDE OF THE
ARGUMENT. ALSO, WOULD YOU HAVE
ANY FOLLOW UP KEEPING IN MIND
THAT THIS IS A RESOLUTION AND
NOT A BILL? ABSOLUTELY. I HAVE A
FOLLOW UP. OKAY. SO MY FOLLOW UP
AGAIN IS LIKE I SAID, THIS
RESOLUTION, HAVE YOU DONE ANY
ANY AT ALL INVESTIGATION OR
OPPOSITE INVESTIGATION AS A
LEGISLATOR ON THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS? YOU JUST MENTIONED A
BILL THAT YOU PULLED BECAUSE IT
HAD SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC IMPACTS.
AND THE REASON I SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE FISHERMEN HAVE BEEN
FISHING SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
TIME, RIGHT? WHETHER IT'S
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES, BACK IN
JESUS'S DAY HERE ON THE TRIBAL
LAND, WHATEVER IT'S BEEN, IT'S
BEEN IN SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
TIME, AND FISH HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
THERE. AND SO I THINK THE
IMPACTS THAT YOU HAVE WITH THESE
COMMERCIAL OR ANGLERS, SPORTS
FISHERMEN IS, IS GOING TO BE
DRASTIC. I HAVE TWO QUICK
ANSWERS TO THAT QUESTION. AND
ONE, THE ANSWER IS YES. AND TWO,
THE ANSWER IS IT IS DIFFICULT TO
DO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT ANALYSIS
OF A RESOLUTION, BECAUSE YOU'D
HAVE TO DO AN ECONOMIC IMPACT
AT, AT ANTICIPATING WHAT THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE IS GOING TO
BE, THAT THE AGENCIES ARE GOING
TO FIND. I DON'T WANT TO GET
AHEAD. ALL WE'RE SAYING IS IT'S
LIKE SAYING CLIMATE IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM. THIS IS A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION WHEN APPLIED PROPERLY.
AND SO THANK YOU. I'LL LEAVE IT
AT THAT. SENATOR DALY AND THEN
SENATOR EGGMAN, I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT REAL QUICK. SO, YOU
KNOW, I'VE BEEN HERE 12 YEARS
AND A RESOLUTION IS NOT A LAW,
BUT IT BASICALLY SAYS THE INTENT
OF WHERE YOU WANT TO GO. SO I'M
JUST GOING TO SAY THIS FOR THE
RECORD. YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
LOOKING FOR SOME REAL
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AROUND HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A RESOLUTION HERE,
BUT WE ARE MARCHING FORWARD TO
PUT OFFSHORE WIND, AND WE'RE NOT
DOING THE HOLISTIC SCIENCE WE
NEED TO DO TO REALLY LOOK AT THE
FULL PICTURE OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING. BUT WE SO WE'RE JUST
PIECEMEAL. WE'RE DOING THIS, WE
DO THAT. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA, AND WE NEED
TO HOLISTICALLY LOOK AT IT WHEN
WE'RE DOING OFFSHORE WIND. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LINES IN THE
OCEAN. YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
THOUSANDS OF LINES OUT THERE
COMING TO THESE PORTS. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I CAN'T SUPPORT
IT. WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
COASTAL OF CALIFORNIA IN A
HOLISTIC WAY WITH THE IMPACTS TO
THE THINGS YOU BROUGHT UP, THE
THINGS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT WITH
OFFSHORE WIND. AND WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT. AND I THINK THAT IS
AN INJUSTICE TO THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT RELY ON THE
COAST FOR MANY THINGS, FOR
FISHING, FOR RECREATION, FOR
HABITAT AND THE NATURAL. THIS IS
THE WRONG WAY TO DO IT, IS IF
YOU PASS THIS, YOU'RE SAYING
THIS IS INTENT WHERE WE WANT TO
GO BY THE LEGISLATURE. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION EITHER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR YOU, BUT, A I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE DOING A
RESOLUTION AT THE LAST MINUTE,
RUSHING IT THROUGH LIKE THIS,
AND B, I AGREE THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE A PLAN, AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS
PLAN. I JUST CAME FROM ANOTHER
COMMITTEE WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
PRIORITIZE THIS KIND OF
TRAINING. SO IT'S THE PATCHWORK
THAT I OBJECT TO. WE ALREADY
HAVE A FOCUS. LET US STAY THE
COURSE. SO I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS
TODAY AND HOPE LIKE I'M A BIG
BELIEVER LIKE WE SHOULD EACH
JUST HAVE TEN BILLS. WE HAVE TEN
BILLS. WE GET THEM DONE THROUGH
THE YEAR, AND WE DON'T JUST KEEP
ADDING AND LAYERING AND LAYERING
AND LAYERING WITHOUT A REAL
FOCUS AND DIRECTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE DAIS, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, I JUST WANT TO ASSOCIATE
MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
FORMER SECRETARY, APPRECIATE
THIS BILL, IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE GET THIS RIGHT, AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP TALKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING
THE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
FISHERMEN, AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU, WITH THAT, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE DO. WE HAVE A MOTION, A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAIRD. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE RESOLUTION BE
ADOPTED, BUT FIRST, BE REFERRED
TO BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. ASSISTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MIN. I MEAN, I CIERTO CIERTO. NO
ALLEN. DALLI. DALLI NO. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. NO. GROVE GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. LAIRD LAIRD I LIMÓN.
PADILLA. PADILLA I STERN. STERN
I. OKAY OKAY. THE VOTE IS FOUR
FOUR. WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THIS MORNING. AND NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO SB 632. SENATOR
CABALLERO, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. YOU MAY BEGIN
PRESENTING WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. MR. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB 632, WHICH WOULD
CREATE CONNECTIVITY FOR AN OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE OR OHV RIDING
AREA AROUND RED ROCK CANYON
STATE PARK AND THE ADJACENT
STATE AND FEDERAL LANDS THAT
ALSO ALLOW OHV RECREATION. THIS
IS BASICALLY TO ALLOW THE ACCESS
BETWEEN THE TWO AREAS THAT ALLOW
THE OHV, IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM TO
ALLOW THEM TO USE THE PUBLIC
ROADS SO THEY DON'T GO OFF ROAD
AND CREATE DAMAGE. WITH A REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
YOU HAVE JUST ONE WITNESS HERE
TODAY. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL HEAR
FROM, MR. SMITH WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES. MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, MARK SMITH, ON
BEHALF OF THE OFF ROAD VEHICLE
LEGISLATIVE COALITION, WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB 632, WHICH WILL
PRESERVE IMPORTANT CONNECTIVITY
FOR RECREATION ENTHUSIASTS WHILE
PROTECTING NATURAL AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES IN ROCK, RED ROCK
CANYON STATE PARK. WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES OR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I HAVE
ONE QUICK COMMENT. WE HAVE ONE
QUICK COMMENT FROM SENATOR. ONE
OF THE SUPPORTING COALITIONS IS
THE JAWBONE COALITION, AND I
ASSUME THEY'VE BEEN ON THE FLOOR
FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS. I
THINK THAT'S TRUE. OKAY I
REQUEST AN I VOTE MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS? OKAY. SENATOR CAVALIER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. OKAY. FANTASTIC WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR GROVE. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED. OH,
WOW. SORRY, GRACIOUS. OH, WOW.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR EGGMAN,
THAT'S SO BIG OF YOU. YES,
THAT'S BIG HEARTED. YEAH VERY
RESPECTFUL, WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR EGGMAN. THE MOTION
IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
BE CONCURRED IN. ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MIN MIN AYE. SEYARTO I C AYE.
ALAN HI, ALAN. AYE. DALLI DALLI.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE GROVE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN PADILLA. HI.
PADILLA. AYE STERN. STERN. AYE
OKAY. SO WE ARE NINE. TRY NINE
ZERO. OKAY. THAT VOTE COUNT IS
NINE ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL NOW
MOVE BACK TO, ACR 210, ASSISTANT,
THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED, BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR ALAN.
ALAN AYE. HURTADO LIMÓN. FIVE.
FOUR. FIVE. OKAY. THAT VOTE IS
FIVE FOUR. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. SENATOR BURRITOS.
ASSISTANT. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
SB 632. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 905
FOR VOTING ON SB SIX 3232, THE
CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO.
SENATOR LEMON, A LIMÓN. AYE.
OKAY. AND WE'LL, I GUESS THE
BILL IS OUT TEN ZERO, OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ACR 210,
MOTION? IS THAT THE RESOLUTION
BE ADOPTED? BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 4. SENATOR LEMON, A
SENATOR LEMON, I MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY. THAT MEASURE PASSES. SIX
FOUR, AND WITH THAT, THANK YOU,
EVERYONE, FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION. WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA. SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.